so I wanted to ask you about the origins
of the film it sounds like it was just
in a sense kind of your instinct to film
many documentaries the filmmakers don't
really have a way of knowing you know
the direction it may go
in this case you didn't even necessarily
have a documentary in mind initially
yeah you're right I I had no intention
of making a documentary when I first
started filming this
um you know when I moved back home from
New York I had all this free time on my
hands and uh prior to the pandemic I
always knew I wanted to share my
family's Story I mean you know if you
think about what my parents a
Mexican-American woman and this
Cambodian Refugee what they were able to
achieve and you know of all places bad
ax Michigan it's the American dream so I
always thought I would like write a
script and you know that would be my way
of sharing that story so I sat down in
those early days of the pandemic doing
two things and one of them was just
getting this whole oral history of how
you know the restaurant came to be what
it is today thinking this was just
research to write a script
um one day so you know just hearing how
like the restaurant came to be you know
not only a success but also like a
pinnacle of what badax Michigan is but
the other part is that instinct right it
was
um and I don't know I don't know if I
necessarily know what the Instinct was
other than knowing it was an important
time in in our lives and knowing I
wanted to just capture that on camera
for I think the reason being just having
these memories and Home Videos to hold
on to
um but I what I when I realized I had a
documentary it was that I wanted to make
a documentary I think was like shortly
after the black lives matter movement
happened
um when I began to see like these
parallel between these two things of
this history of this American dream I
just had on camera in these early days
but also like that our family was still
fighting so hard to keep that alive uh
in 2020 in the face of you know a
pandemic and racial Reckoning and
everything that was you know a
politically divided nation I mean it was
like oh this is the way to tell the
story of the American dream was a
documentary and that's just the way it
just naturally unfolded yeah the way
everything collided I think is just
opens a window onto the entire country
not simply yeah a small town in Michigan
I'm curious what it was like for you
growing up in bad acts because you know
as I think we see in the film and for
anyone who follows the news or social
media clearly the country is far more
polarized maybe than it ever has been so
things are getting worse in that respect
what was it like as a as a kid in that
town I mean you know life growing up in
bad acts
um
when I look back on it I am very
grateful for the childhood I had growing
up in the upbringing I had because you
know badax is such a it's it's like my
brother-in-law says it's such a
tight-knit community where everyone
knows everyone and
um and people do take care of each other
there
um having said that you know just like
any small town in anywhere in the U.S it
has its problems you know
um especially when it comes to racism
um so yeah you know I I experience
racism
um more often than anyone should growing
up uh you know being called Jackie Chan
and Bruce Lee and you know even being
called you know the n-word because my
skin is is a darker color like those
were all things I experienced growing up
um and I always felt embarrassed or or
ashamed of that which it took moving
away from Bad acts and gaining that
perspective of you know I guess like
going to Ann Arbor Michigan and living
in LA and living in New York knowing
that like why am I embarrassed of that
you know
um I'm actually the one that's not the
problem here it's it's the the way of
thinking that some of these individuals
have in this community that that needs
to open up and needs to change
um but you know that's that's what it
came with growing up in bad acts and
those experiences you know I say it's a
love letter to bad X because it really
is
um
that that love is unconditional because
it's what made me who I am today and
it's what made our family who we are
today you know you take the good with
the bad with that
and you mentioned the black lives matter
protest which is such an extraordinary
scene and very upsetting I think for the
audience to watch uh let alone for you
to be there in the midst of it but
whether it was that scene or others what
was um the hardest parts of of making
the film was that those kind of moments
or
senior father be so vulnerable at times
on camera which
a little I don't know scary is the word
for Hassan to see that but yeah it was
God it was It was kind of all of it I
mean
um you know speaking of my dad first I
mean he always shared his stories about
surviving the genus you know the Killing
Fields growing up
um but what he didn't ever really share
was how those stories affected who he is
as a dad as the person who he is today
it really took those hour-long
conversations of having the camera
pointed at him for him to really open up
about that and I don't know if that was
more hard for me as more I was just
thankful actually really grateful he was
willing to share those emotions he never
did before with me because you know
during the pandemic he had all this free
time on his hands just like we all did
right and it gave him a lot of time to
think and
yes he's a Storyteller but like I said
like it's it's one thing to tell these
stories it's another thing to talk about
like how they actually you know have
affected who you are in the trauma that
comes with that
um so I was grateful he was willing to
open up about that stuff
um but I think you know like if we're
talking about like the more difficult
sides of making this film it really came
along in the editing process
um
it's easy for me to pick up a camera and
film these moments you know it it truly
is because that's what I've just kind of
done my whole life it's another thing to
take those moments and start editing
them together to tell a story and
especially when that story is is about
your family because you know as you've
seen my family is very opinionated
um no
um so everybody had their own ideas
about what the film should be and you
had some co-directors I had a lot of
co-directors
um but I'll say that you know like in
those early editing days
um I I think I I kind of lost track of
eyes in this film in the first place and
wanted to be this filmmaker that stood
up on my soapbox and
he you know pointed out everything that
was wrong with our country you're just
yelling into the echo Chambers and you
know my family was the one that's like
you're not gonna change people's you
know you're not gonna open up people's
hearts by doing that like why are you
even doing this in the first place and
it really took those tough conversations
with them to come to the answer to that
which was
um
were actually quite simple which was the
love I had for my family and wanting to
share their story of resilience and
coming back to the answer of love I
think is what uh the film needed in
order for it to you know take the final
um form that it currently has because
you know with this film I I
when I came to that conclusion I
realized like I can't preach to people I
I don't need to preach to people I just
need to show you know and tell this
personal story that I wanted to start
doing from the first place and then
these like messages and these themes
naturally unveil themselves in a way
where
um through an empathetic lens versus you
know like trying to tell you you're
wrong if you disagree because the film
you know at the end of the day it's not
trying to do that it's just trying to
show an experience that might be
different from others you know growing
up in towns like bad ax Michigan things
that fascinated me about the film you
know you begin it with that letter
that was sent and sort of a happy font
style almost so I was like is that comic
sensor Sans serif and only it was but it
it sort of belied the the the tone of it
yeah but the person saying that you know
we stand for traditional American values
yes but what are those values yeah
that's that's something that really got
to me because like I think in the
process of making this film
um one of the things I really want
audiences to walk away with is looking
at my family as being more American than
any other family because you know when
when people think of the Civ family you
know my family they might not think of
us as your traditional American family
but the reality is that America is a
country that's built on immigrants and
refugees and what my family experience
during the pandemic make was what so
many other families from from you know
not even backgrounds like ours but from
all backgrounds experience right and
like so therefore like that's the
American experience and
you know with that you know
um I I hope like you know when people
view our family it opens up their idea
of what the American family is you know
so when people you know when we got that
letter and it's like traditional
American values it's like what is that
those are your traditional American
values it's not everyone's you know
traditional American values it's like
when Jacqueline says like bad X is still
our hometown
it's true it's just as much as my home
as it is any of my neighbors home you
know
um and that was that really played the
influence in naming the film bad X too
um because at first we're like oh like
are people gonna be turned off that Civ
family you know we're the ones making a
film called badax because we're far
different than anyone else in our
community but then I thought about like
no I have every right to make a film
called bad X and anybody else in this
town
yeah when I first saw the title I
thought wow that's a great name for a
horror film
we get that a lot but you know it
creates Intrigue which I guess is not a
bad thing you know I'm sure there's a
story about how the town got named maybe
for another time but um how do you think
the film has sort of the process of
making it and then bring it out into the
world and go into so many film festivals
which by the way it's won many awards
including your world premiere at South
by Southwest where you won an award in
the audience award
um but how is it sort of changed your
family or do you think it has I think
one of the things documentaries can do
of that nature is people get to say
things that they just wouldn't otherwise
yeah I I honestly say that you know we
were a close family
um even before making this and now that
the film has been out there and we're on
this journey of promoting the film
together as a family it's really only
brought us that much closer together
um you know we're I was talking about
earlier we're in the middle of a 45-day
road trip right now just across the
country promoting the film and we're so
grateful you know my parents never got
to travel at all
um uh prior to this year they our idea
of vacation was driving three hours of
Toronto and spending two days there and
now they've seen every corner of the
country in the past month and we've
gotten to just you know spend time
together and celebrate and share a story
and have conversations with other people
it's something that you know I I'm so
grateful for and
um to be able to do that together as a
family is just it's just made us that
much closer and much so much stronger
together
um I I don't take any of it for granted
I don't think they do either
well it's a tremendous film I personally
speak for myself think it's one without
a doubt one of the finest documentaries
of the year and one that I think is
really gonna Gonna Last and let's touch
so many people I'm sure others in the
audience tonight as well so let's thank
David Zeb for this thank you so much
thank you for sticking around
[Applause]